and is chairman of an international
private intelligence firm and author of
the new book America's secret war it
looks at surreptitious offensive being
conducted by the United States against
many countries and terrorist
organizations this talk from book people
in Austin Texas is just over an hour
good evening everybody I'm Mike Shea and
it's my pleasure to welcome you all to
this 35th edition of the Texas Monthly
author series our event is a group
discussion your comments and questions
are invited at any time when you're
called on please raise your hand I'll
call on you stand up and wait for the
boom mic to reach you so that we can
catch your remarks for tape the Texas
Monthly authors series has hosted all
kinds of writers including Nobel Prize
winners Emmy winning newscasters in a
particular former governor of Texas the
tonight's guest probably has deeper
insight into the real workings of world
politics and conflict than anyone I've
ever interviewed his book is America's
secret war inside the hidden worldwide
struggle between America and its enemies
it's a timely bestseller about the US
war on terror and the invasions of
Afghanistan and Iraq its author is the
founder of Stratfor one of the world's
leading private sources of geopolitical
intelligence please welcome George
Friedman that just gets started
Stratfor which stands for strategic
forecasting it's a privately held
company right and you provide analysis
of geopolitical events and trends to all
sorts of clients how was the concept of
Stratfor developed well I was a
professor at Louisiana State University
and didn't want to keep doing that
anymore
and it struck me that the whole shape of
intelligence had changed but nobody's
realized it back in the 1950s you would
send an agent into Kiev to get a
newspaper was that hard to get you spent
a million dollars in the operation and
it would come out and they'd read it and
they'd look at the want ads things of
that sort and try to understand what's
going on the internet had started and
suddenly I could read the same newspaper
for free now immediately the CIA assumed
it wasn't worth anything because it was
easy to get so they stopped worrying
about that but from my point of view
that same newspaper was incredibly
valuable and if we could do all of that
pull that together we could get and
under
Danny of the world that rivaled what 10
years ago only National Intelligence
Agency had now what's your what you're
talking about
this doesn't really sound like rocket
science to me if you're if you're
basically picking up apples that have
fallen on the ground is what it sounds
like
what makes Stratfor's analysis so much
more valuable or so much more credible
than anybody else well first that's how
we started and the interesting thing
about the Internet is its value has
declined over the past few years and
simply because people have understood
that with Google what they put out there
is going to stay there forever and
they've gotten a lot more careful to
make sure that the only thing they put
out there is what they want out there so
the paradox is that we're the beginning
intelligence became easier its value
really dropped so we had to go back to
some more traditional forms of
intelligence gathering which is putting
people on the ground in unpleasant
places it's still easier to communicate
with them we don't need a 42 million
dollars sadnesses satellite system a
hotmail account will do but still we
have to go back in on the ground but the
most important part of intelligence is
the part that's most neglected by
intelligence organizations its analysis
an analysis is the ability to look at
things and see the hidden patterns that
are there and there is a discipline to
it as well as an art but the most
important element of intelligence is
what alcohol courage it is believing
what you see even if nobody else sees
the same thing and that includes all the
ideologues all of the pundits and
everyone else the whole purpose of
Stratfor was to create an environment in
which analysts could see the patterns
call them without fear of retribution
that sounds like a simple thing but in
the world of intelligence it isn't
because in the world of intelligence
virtually everything you say has
consequences and somebody wants to
control what it is used to say and
Stratfor is a very simple idea the only
people we were beholden to were
customers they were buying us because
of what we said was true we had no
reason not to be courageous
so courage became easy or it didn't come
courage and that really made a huge
difference I think so who would be a
typical strat for client and without
being indelicate what's it cost
well we have two divisions we call them
divisions because it makes us sound
important one we have a website and we
have about a hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers to that website and you can
buy that website ranging from real cheap
1995 year to $400 a year depending on
how much detail you want now we have
another division that does work
primarily for corporations answering
questions that you would be
breathtakingly uninterested not really
geopolitical questions although they're
interested in that but questions like
we're looking to invest in a company in
Kazakhstan does that company actually
own the thing they claim to own in
Kazakhstan that's always an exciting
question so what we do for them is
answer simple intelligence questions
with very little analysis what we do for
the public website you know our
subscription is a lot of analysis with
just we hope the right amount of
intelligence and if you're not the 1995
customer you're the much more expensive
customer well if you're not 1995 for
$400 a year you can find out from us
what is actually happening the Ivory
Coast which is important but a lot of
people don't care and if 1995 will
probably tell you what's going on a
Fallujah which just about everybody
should care about but there are a lot of
areas in the world that important things
are happening but most of us don't need
to know about or don't need to know
about in the detail we provide so we try
to calibrate it to the appetite of the
customer your book is called America's
secret war at the outset you refer to
the current situation Marquez war on
terror as the
fourth global war two questions do you
think that the current situation the
current conflict really merit a
comparison to world war two World War
one and what's that third global war
that well that's missing in there all
wars are different and if you benchmark
it you could argue the Cold War wasn't a
war now we fought in Vietnam we fought
in Korea a lot of good people died in a
lot of places didn't look like the
Second World War but it had a coherent
ongoing theme it was a struggle between
two nations two ideologies and it flowed
around the world this war the fourth one
is interesting because it is a struggle
between a nation state the United States
and a non national organization or a
transnational organization and what's
different about it is that one organism
one is very large country the most
powerful country in the world and one is
a superb covert operation now normally
we would not treat a covert operation as
a war but this one operates differently
they built it differently they hit us
hard and they hurt us they move around
they hit other places we send in bombers
they send in suicide squads the weapons
are different but there are a
fundamental global interests at stake
between the two sides both sides is
smart both sides are capable and it
swirls around the globe it's very hard
to follow but it's a war people are
dying
militaries are involved and its global
so I would call it a war between the
newest Empire in the world and a
collapsed Empire the Islamic empire as
it searches to resurrect itself and the
American Empire tries to figure out what
it is now the the al-qaeda of course
everyone knows about al-qaeda now ten
years ago
very few of us know anything about
what were the origins of al-qaeda has it
been around forever but the tendency
toward al-qaeda has been around for very
long time while hobby ism from which it
merges has been around for several
centuries but the tendency to want to
create an Islamic empire to recreate
what they called a caliphate has been an
impulse that has been there ever since
the Islamic world tore itself apart was
torn apart by Christianity so the
tendency has been there
however al-qaeda really originates in
the Soviet invasion of Afghanistan and
with Jimmy Carter when the Soviets
invaded Afghanistan right after the Iran
hostage crisis the United States was
terrified they believe this was a
precursor of a Soviet move into Iran to
seize the oil fields of the Persian Gulf
war games carried out several place
include US Army War College and one of
the things we discovered is we didn't
have a conventional military counter so
the question to the president as
President Carter asked was what do we do
if they move into Iran and the answer
that came back basically from the
military is not a whole lot Carter and
Brzezinski crafted a strategy to bog the
Soviets down in a guerilla war in
Afghanistan and Carter signed the
finding which was necessary to carry out
covert operations but the United States
was not in a position to even do that we
had no assets in Afghanistan so we
turned to Saudi Arabia and the Saudis
were asked to provide two things money
and a recruitment network now they we
wanted to recruit from the jihadists the
fundamentalists but remember the
strategy of the United States throughout
this period was to use religion against
the Soviet Union
your Soviet Jews liqui lenses solidarity
in Poland was a quasi religious entity
linked closely to the Catholic Church
using religiosity against the Soviets
was something we liked a threeway
Alliance was created on the one side
there was Saudi Arabia
Pakistan provided training facilities
and its intelligence service to support
them the United States provided a
wraparound support these jihadists
fought the Soviets to a standstill and
defeated them this was the first major
military victory of the Islamic world
against what we call the West they'll
call the Christians in centuries it was
a absolutely galvanizing event they not
only defeated the Soviet Union they
brought it down in their view it was the
Afghan war that brought down the Soviet
Union that a case could be made that
they were right once the war was over
so was the Soviet Union United States
lost all interest in the jihadists and
the shahadat
weren't even given papers to go back
home so if you think about the American
Vietnam vets and how bitter they were
felt at the end of the war that's not a
tenth of what does your hottest fell
toward the Saudis toward the Pakistanis
toward the Americans when they were left
high and dry in Afghanistan isolated and
alone now were these farm boys or these
well-trained well trained individuals on
the whole uh there were wide range of
people but on the whole they were fairly
educated not poor they pay their own way
they were drawn from some of the highest
strata of society and Osama is not
unique and he's very wealthy but Osama
bin Laden was one of these men and you
know they they were not the oppressed of
the Islamic world
they were the if you want religiously
dispossessed and so when that war ended
these people were hardened combat
capable covert operatives trained by the
CIA knowledgeable about how we operate
knowledgeable about how to defeat the
CIA and bitterly angry at what they
regard as betrayal from their own
government when the United States
intervened in Desert Storm and place US
troops in a Saudi Arabia that was the
break point for them was that was the
ultimate defilement of the land of Mecca
Medina the Arabian Peninsula and that
galvanized them to start
to think about how to take on the United
States and that sounds crazy but from
their point of view they just taken down
the Soviet Union why not take on the
United States in their analysis the
problem was of course not the United
States it was their own governments and
so they began to craft a plan in 92 93
about how to start not in the next year
not in the next decade that next century
perhaps how to start reconstructing the
Islamic empire and that was the origin
of al Qaeda which means the base which
they had in Afghanistan after the
students the Taliban won their civil war
there now of course we all started
paying attention to al Qaeda on
September 11th but there are a lot of a
lot of actions by al Qaeda
prior to that that we should have been
paying attention to shouldn't we and did
the United States government have them
on the radar there was a question
everyone had them on the radar here was
the problem the United States was used
to a form of Arab terrorism that they
experienced in 1970s and 1980s a Black
September Hezbollah groups of this sort
they were fairly contained and what they
did they would hijack an airliner here
they would kidnap some people there they
had no global ambitions and we lived
with that sort of terrorism really since
the late 1960s and it was to use John
Kerry's and felicitous phrase a nuisance
but certainly one that could be lived
with the mistake that was made was that
when Al Qaeda merged nobody understood
how extraordinarily different this group
was from everything to come before
everybody including me in early 90s was
intellectually lazy we said okay here
comes an other Arab terrorist group and
we've seen Arab terrorist groups it's
not something worth going to war over
you don't really have to send covert
operatives to kill
we put them in a box and said they'll
stay there and we didn't really look at
how they started or where they were
going so it's not that we didn't see
them it's we didn't recognize them for
what they were and we didn't take them
seriously and this is one of the
greatest defects about al-qaeda that
exists today to this day we either
underestimate them or overestimate them
either they're of no consequence
whatsoever or they're ten foot tall
monsters are going to eat us so the
stereotype that we've all lived with of
of terrorists is is this this kind of
this kind of madman driving an old
Toyota pickup truck with a bomb in the a
bomb in the glove box al Qaeda was
completely different from that they they
were more sophisticated they had they
had different ambitions their political
goals were more sophisticated in Lebanon
where a great deal of terrorism went on
most of the kidnappings were local it
was positioned one group in relationship
to an other group Palestinian terrorism
for example
frequently had less to do with the
people they were kidnapping than the
position one group Popular Front for the
Liberation of Palestine against another
group in internal politics Al Queda had
global ambitions its ambitions were far
beyond those of any of the prior groups
moreover where all the prior groups are
really secular their goals were to
participate in kind of secular
revolution al Qaeda's goals were deeply
religious and that changed the entire
tempo of their operations and of their
perspective al Qaeda was much different
in every sense of the word but US
intelligence looked at them and said oh
I seen this before it's okay
you say in the book that September 11th
Osama bin Laden certainly knew that that
was not going to bring America down but
he had a more devious purpose there walk
us through your analysis of what his
strategy was and what he really hoped to
accomplish with September 11th Osama saw
the fundamental problem the Islamic
world not as the Christians and always
remember he using term Christians not
Western we use Western listen to
Christians it was what he called the
hypocritical governments of the Islamic
world and by that he meant governments
that were formally Islamic but in fact
whose leaders made deals with the United
States made deals with Russia basically
would sell out what he wanted to do was
to create a mass rising in the Islamic
world and toppled at least one
preferably more of these governments and
create the foundation of the Caliphate
here we can fight he knew he needed a
nation-state
he knew that he wasn't going to get
where he wanted to go just by being a
conspiracy the question was how to
create this uprising in his analysis his
view of the of the United States was
that the United States was inherently
weak he looked at the u.s. in Beirut in
the 1980s in Somalia our failure to
defeat Saddam Hussein from his point of
view and he said look the United States
is incapable of waging war and this by
the way was a general view in the
Islamic world the view we have of
ourselves as everybody knows how tough
we are that wasn't the view in the
Islamic world the Islamic the world view
there was take 12 casualties and we're
out of there the u.s. does not have the
moral fiber fight Osama wanted to
demonstrate that
he wanted to get the United States to
strike and get bogged down or to refuse
to strike and confirm in the Islamic
world that he was weak he didn't care
which really it could have been either
one either plunge in and demonstrate
you're the enemy or don't do anything
and demonstrate your weak even one he
thought was going to get him what he
wanted he began attacking American
facilities the embassies in East Africa
the USS Cole and he was looking for a
threshold that the United States could
not tolerate Bill Clinton would not bite
now this built up this perception of
u.s. weakness but not definitively was
frankly the attacks were not sufficient
to really come on the radar screen for
very long he felt he had to craft a
definitive attack that was one that
either the United States could not
decline combat with or would decline
combat prove his thesis about the United
States and energized the Islamic masses
as they had in Afghanistan and that was
the origin of the thinking of September
11th to hit the United States in such a
way in such an enormous ly shocking way
that the United States would either be
seen as weak or would charge as wild
bull into the Islamic world
interestingly he now claims that the
bring down the World Trade Center was
not his intention he didn't expect it to
happen he was and he said that several
times she was really surprised pleased
but surprised you know that it came down
that way but obviously you know God
wanted that to happen but he very
carefully crafted a strategy him and his
aides up to create this event and have
that be a punctuation market Islamic
history
now you can just stand there he can
reach you yeah like the dr. Friedman to
comment on there's been some comments
from for example congressman Ron Paul
talking about a type of marque and
reprisal type of responses buzz what
we're doing like to have your comment
whether that be worse or better or how
that would be different well we had the
reprisal strategy under Clinton Clinton
essential strategy was we would in
response to an event take moderate
action demonstrably that didn't deter
al-qaeda nor on the other hand of the
Boggs down in a war the problem that we
had and we all have to remember back to
that day how we felt it was we have come
to the amnesia after September 11th
measured response was very difficult a
political situation occurred in the
United States because of September 11th
that utterly got galvanized the public I
remember Alan Dershowitz arguing on CNN
in favor of torture now Alan Dershowitz
now butter wouldn't melt in his mouth
but I was on that show and I remember
you know he made the case of that we
were in a state of shock all of us we
were stunned by what happened he had
achieved what he wanted a psychological
pivot in the United States that would
override prudence or so impair Eliza's
that nothing could happen and the
problem that Bush had at that moment was
and this is what restrained him he
didn't have many military options so
sending a couple of cruise missiles at a
milk factory where a aspirin factory in
Sudan wasn't going to work but the
United States was no position to have a
wholesale invasion of the Islamic world
I'd had to come over time and so is the
very weakness of the American military
position in response that kind of
constrained us but I think the arguments
that of the response syndrome assumes
that the United States can indefinitely
tolerate attacks
so if you respond then the other guy
doesn't get deterred how many attacks
are you going to get sir I believe if
there's a some thinking that the House
of Saud is slowly but surely losing
control of the cut of the country and
that should that occur what form would
it take and what do you think the
response would be of this country
there's no question of the House of Saud
has problems I doubt very much it is
losing control the country because the
House of Saud in many ways has become
the country through political family
business relationships it has always
managed to create a situation
particularly at $50 a barrel oil where
the stability of the House of Saud
matters to more people than not that's
one of the problems al-qaeda had when it
attacked inside the country they were
able to shut it down because there was
just a lot of people so who there were a
lot of people who didn't want to see it
full I think the House of Saud is more
resilient than that not immortal by any
means but I've been really impressed by
the way it's absorbed the attack by
al-qaeda over the past few months and
managed to stabilize sir
I read that Osama originally had 15
planes in mind but scaled it back to
four why was that scaling okay
essentially because there were we have
to go into the planning of operation it
had to be simultaneous attacks
everywhere it had to take place with
large aircraft and transcontinental
flights for the fuel and it had to take
place when everybody was at work now
that meant that you could fly out of
Boston Philadelphia New York Washington
those were four airports they were
trained on 767 757s which limited
further the number of aircraft that were
available and you have to take them all
at about the same time because they knew
once the hijackings were underway
they were ground the fleet as they did
the plan for an afternoon attack or
morning so so you can start the attack
at about 8 o'clock in the morning East
Coast time
it's 5 o'clock in the morning West Coast
time there are no transcontinental
flights taking off and what asama did
and the planning was amazing you know
how carefully was thought-out I said
look we're never going to get a shot at
the West Coast the only thing we can do
is shove the East Coast flights over
into the late afternoon but air traffic
control delays make it very unlikely
that everybody's going to take off the
best time to launch an attack is in the
fall because the weather early in the
morning before the system starts to
overload and if you want to take out the
East Coast sometime around 8:30 9:30
okay that precludes the West Coast
operation
apart from security considerations I
mean how many teams can you have running
around and not be detected by the agency
or the FBI he also determined you
couldn't have a simultaneous attack what
he seems to decided to do was hold the
other teams in reserve I think there
were other teams but I think they've
been broken apart by now by various
arrests and so on but I think you know
he reasoned it through and he realized
he wasn't going to be able to get more
than four off the ground in close enough
sequence to be able to be successful it
is really an amazing thing to look at
how this was planned these are superb
covert operatives
one of the interesting things in the
book was to note that when they were
planning this and they were planning the
flights you don't really think about the
Internet's impact but they were able to
see how many people were going to be on
these planes by looking at the seating
charts they wanted planes with
relatively few people on board because
it'd be easy to control now I can go on
Travelocity by ticket try to pick a seat
and know exactly how many are each
flight if you'll take a look each of
those flights we're only about 25% full
so that means they knew how many were on
flight and I tried to figure out how in
God's name they could get that lucky and
I sat down with my computer and lo and
behold Travelocity told me which 757
767s had lo we're going transcontinental
with few passengers now what other ways
have terrorists found to to use the use
the Internet to their advantage well
driving us crazy primarily first you
hear a great deal about Islamic chatter
on the Internet
I will promise you Osama is next
operation will not be posted on the web
those who know don't talk those who talk
don't know but given the current you
know and you know as an intelligence guy
I've got to look at that and say look I
can't just discount it you know somebody
says on such-and-such a date and
such-and-such a day
I'm going to blow up this building what
do you do ignore it no so the FBI goes
charging off to the building another
site somebody says I'm gonna blow up the
Golden Gate Bridge
if days off what al Qaeda is doing with
that is two things first it's pinging
the system and by that I mean they're
mapping out the responses that we give
they can tell what we respond to what we
do don't respond to and try to give up
give themselves a sense of what's going
on because they post it on the web they
stand by the Golden Gate Bridge and I
say who here they Kim that was four
hours very good
we now know what it is the other thing
they do is they dull our alertness
nothing does or alertness more than
multiple false alarms and so they pump
false alarms into us and you get these
and you say so if I ignore this one and
it happens what are they going to say on
the other hand what you're doing is
running around constantly on alerts up
and down and al-qaida is controlling it
we also have our responses we drive
al-qaeda nuts you may have your opinion
of the Patriot Act and it's flawed in
many ways but we don't know who al-qaeda
is in the country but we know roughly
who they hang out with we go in and we
arrest a bunch of people we don't know
who they are but al-qaeda does so if we
get lucky and bagged one and he
disappears for a week now they have to
figure is he talking was he always a
plant who is this guy and al-qaeda is
risk averse crazy to say about people
crash into buildings but they have very
few operatives and therefore every
operation has to count and al-qaeda has
a basic rule abort operations in the
face of security so the United States
conducts what appears to be and really
is I suspect ran the Marisa in the hopes
of statistically bagging somebody and
confusing the living daylights out of
al-qaeda and forcing them to abort
missions back in July we saw a worldwide
wave of arrests including impact Stan in
Saudi Arabia here in the United States
uh which I think had a great deal to do
with the fact that they wound up not
being a pre-election attack I think
al-qaeda wanted one
I think al-qaeda was planning one but I
think it was sufficiently disrupted that
al-qaeda decided not to take a risk and
sir dr. Friedman wanted thank you for
coming my name is Robert Stack I'm a
young American in your book you talk
about you're talking about pinging and
how al-qaeda plays chess what are two
actionable items in your opinion that
the Bush administration can do over the
next four years to change the
geopolitical situation that we're in
right now why that's an extraordinarily
difficult question because the situation
changes hourly but I mean the
fundamental issues this the United
States can't defeat al-qaeda directly
you can only defeat al-qaeda indirectly
by forcing Islamic intelligence services
to work on American behalf so the ISI
the inter-service intelligence
inter-service intelligence in Pakistan
knows a great deal about al-qaeda so do
the Saudis they are able to operate in
ways we aren't now they don't
necessarily find in their interest to
risk fighting al-qaeda the United States
therefore has to change their calculus
of risk and reward so we have what I
call the Coalition of the coursed
they're not happy but they're more
afraid of us than we are than they are
of al-qaeda at the beginning of the war
the Saudis didn't cooperate with the
United States they were more afraid of
al-qaeda than the United States and
reasonably so what the United States has
done over the past couple of years is
changed that equation now that has not
given us defeat a victory over al-qaeda
not by any means but it has moved it has
moved the situation from one in which
al-qaeda is completely opaque to which
there is a degree of knowledge of what
they're intending to do and therefore
the possibility of countering them in
the end this remains a nation-state game
in the end it can be defeated by
nation-states
but in the end it has to be in the
interest of the nation states to do what
they do
one of the challenges that anyone faces
when they're trying to conduct a Counter
Terrorist action is making this the
distinction between Wars and crimes talk
a little bit if you would about the
difference between a criminal act an act
of war how that affects the United
States prosecuting a war on terrorism
domestically and then outside of its own
borders well let me begin by saying the
United States has absolutely no law
competent to deal with an al Qaeda we've
never confronted this and our laws and
applicable if a crime is committed you
want to rest the criminals and no one
else and the principle of our legal
system is better the ten should go free
than one innocent person be harmed it's
pretty good principle the principle of
war is better than a hundred innocent
should be killed than one not guilty but
one target not be taken out so during
world war two and fighting Nazi Germany
we certainly accepted the principle that
civilians should be killed not because
this person was guilty or innocent
because the target was valuable you have
a completely different view of the world
if you're at war or if you're engaged in
criminal activity now for US war is a
nation-state we understand that our law
understands that we deal with that okay
so the example I use is when we invaded
Guadalcanal in the World War two it was
not because the Islanders had been in
collusion with the Japanese or that they
had supported doctrines of Bushido or
anything insane like that it had an
airbase Henderson field and we wanted it
the Islanders were just the poor guys
who were caught there in a criminal
prosecution
you must be surgically careful not to
harm anyone else
you cannot defeat al-qaeda through the
criminal justice system you will not get
proof beyond a reasonable doubt you will
not even get proof more importantly
imagine this example that after Pearl
Harbor we dedicated ourselves to finding
every Japanese pilot who flew that
attack and we're committed to bring him
to justice not Japan not holding the
state responsible just the pilots it
would be a kind of madness built into
that now Bush managed to confuse the
issue entirely by simultaneously calling
for the prosecution of the criminals and
the waging of a war on terror you don't
wage a war on terror terrorism means of
warfare
you know wage war a naval power you wage
war an enemy there's an enemy's called
al Qaeda you expand it to the jihadists
but there's a fight there's an enemy
you're trying to defeat one of the
things about the Bush administration has
been in my view that it's public
enunciation of the war has been
essentially incoherent while its
prosecution of the war has actually been
surprisingly effective but here right at
the beginning are we going to arrest and
bring to justice these people are we
going to destroy the organization al
Qaeda well we have no framework and
still have no framework for dealing with
this the Patriot Act doesn't deal with
many of the issues international law
doesn't deal with many of the issues so
those who oppose the war say we should
obey international law and the question
is which one and those who want the war
say international law well it should be
or should not be who knows what they say
we are in a legal chaos and as a result
the conceptual basis the wars in a legal
case
after after September 11th there was a
huge fear there there was there was
widespread fear of just about everything
there was certainly a huge fear that
there was going to be some sort of a
nuclear attack on the United States by
by terrorists two questions one how
valid was that fear - given the size of
the United States and the size of our
borders with Mexico and Canada can we
ever have truly effective homeland
security here well I think homeland
security is an impossibility it's
certainly against a small what I call a
sparse global network there are too few
of them they operate all over the world
we will never detect ah that's the
dilemma that really faces the United
States when we take all the ideology and
everything out is you can't defend the
homeland you can create a home
department of homeland defense and put
Tom Ridge in charge and assert that
you're defending the homeland and
there's a value to that I mean you don't
you know we had air raid wardens in the
Second World War
probably wouldn't do much but it makes
you feel better but the problem is you
can only win this particular war
offensively there's no defensive measure
that you can take that's credible about
nuclear weapons I mean there was
certainly absolute fear in October of
2001 that a nuclear weapon was in play I
talked about in the book the problem was
that a report came in from a Russian
source that a suitcase bomb was missing
suitcase bomb is a small nuclear device
large enough to do tremendous damage
that by itself wouldn't have impressed
anybody except almost at the same time a
pakistani source provided the serial
numbers of a bomb and said that it was
in new york already now when one dubious
source tells you something is just
dubious source
but when two dubious sources who totally
have never met each other tell you the
same thing now you have a problem the
problem was no bidding you what in the
world to do defensively back at that
question the word was that a nuclear
device was in or moving toward New York
okay let's say that you set up a nuclear
detector on the GW bridge George
Washington Bridge and you detect there
may be a nuclear device on board that
what do you do if you attack it goes off
if you don't attack it'll go off when
they want how do you cope with it so
they ran war games and simulations I
think that was the defining moment of
the war for the Bush administration it
was kept secret from the public at the
time because there was nothing to be
done
wasn't sure it was true but the Bush
administration then turned its attention
away just from al-qaeda but the whole
question of securing nuclear weapons
which really hadn't been addressed
properly and I think the trauma to the
to the planners was just incalculable
you're sitting there as president your
vice president is in an other spot
hidden away you're afraid to be in the
same city and now your intelligence
director George Tenet comes to the White
House and says we have credible reports
that there's a nuclear weapon in New
York at that point I think the United
States went to the next level because at
that point it suddenly hit everyone how
catastrophic this all could become and
the helpless that's really sank in on
the administration the president
realized he could wake up tomorrow
morning
lost 1 2 3 cities and he didn't have any
counter the desperate need to get
control of the situation by any means
whatsoever was driven home no device was
exploded in New York no one ever found a
nuclear weapon we still don't know if
there's one in play I suspect there
isn't because the other side we've used
it earlier rather than risk losing it
but still that moment in late October
when Tennant goes to the president and
he suddenly faces the abyss the way I
don't think any president has before him
he thought he was going to lose New York
completely transformed his thinking
about all of this he went to extremes
because in his mind the situation had
gone to an extreme again his ability to
articulate this was minimal but there
was a reason for that he didn't want to
go on national television and tell the
country how frightened he was that would
have done no good and so he did what he
tends to do in crisis tough it out smirk
a little look confident but anybody who
was not terrified at that point was not
in touch with reality and that was the
problem which is that there were some
who retrospectively look at this period
and say I would have been as calm then
as I am now even if I knew with the
president and the fact of the matter was
that it was a terrifying time for
particularly the leaders particularly
because they didn't know what to do
you had a question in the back and then
this gentleman here
we tend to I think a lot in America look
at the Islamic world and the Islamic
threat is some sort of monolithic thing
or with varying degrees of intensity but
isn't it true that in fact among Muslims
and different types of Muslims there's a
lot of rivalry and mistrust and all and
could you comment on that and and the
extent to which that affects how we wage
a war if you will against terrorism sure
I mean that's absolutely true I mean the
weakness of the Islamic world is that
it's a deeply fragmented divided entity
constantly in or on the verge of civil
war the most fundamental distinction if
you will is the Sunni Shiite distinction
and the United States has manipulated
that fairly effectively in Iraq playing
off the Shiite region which is remained
relatively quiet against the Sunnis and
trying to convince the Sunnis to back
off because of the relationship of the
Shiites that's certainly one critical
dimension I mean we have to remember
that the United States went into Iraq
and into Afghanistan in a collaborative
relationship with Iran the Iranians the
Shiites are terribly afraid of Al Qaeda
who are Wahabi ah
they've occasionally maneuvered with
them there's no reason not to do that
but it was the Iranians who badly wanted
an American invasion of Iraq for two
reasons one they were afraid of al Qaeda
but more to the point they wanted to
neutralize Saddam who had waged a
terrible war against the Iranians and
was terribly afraid the United States
would not go into Iraq they waged a very
skillful intelligence campaign to get us
in there they also helped us
substantially in Afghanistan where the
Shiites and projects that the Iranians
are very close to cooperate with the
United States so any simplistic model of
the Islamic world is going to fail and
one of the weaknesses of a summer that
he's never quite come to grips with in
his speaking in discussion is he
represents a Sunni majority that Sunni
majority itself is divided
and then there's a division between the
Sunnis and the Shiites the United States
and then there are other divisions as
well secular versus religious and and
other levels it is a saving grace
because of the Islamic world were more
United they would not be manageable and
the United States uses these tools very
imperfectly those they're imperfect
tools to kind of manage and manipulate
the situation as well as possible this
gentleman right here I'm glad I came
here to hear you speak I've got two
questions the first one could be very
real quick answered by yes or no and
that is do you agree that the night of
the final 9/11 Commission report is a
whitewash and coverup and the second
question which I hope you'll expound on
if you can hope you can't expand on it
is that p-tech is a high tech company
that was founded by an apparent foreign
terrorist financier and it had contracts
high tech contracts ensue and top-secret
access with the Army Navy Defense
Department the Air Force Secret Service
FAA and it knew about the protocols of
communications between the FAA and NORAD
so how can one how could you for example
if you wanted to determine whether
p-tech was the CIA front or any other
comments you might have a better well
first no I don't know I doubt regardless
of whitewash I regard as an excellent
report it's of all the Commission's
we've had in our history most of which
are grouped Rochas this is the one I
think that the best I don't know the
case of p-tech I can't comment on it but
I think there's more than enough
conspiracy going around not to compound
it with more in the sense that al-qaeda
is quite capable on its own of carrying
out these attacks
the idea that and I want to come down
very strongly on that that somewhere in
the United States the US had an interest
in seeing the Pentagon attacked and the
World Trade Center destroyed is I think
with all due respect sir preposterous
and I don't think it really adds much to
the conversation
gentleman right here how stable do you
think Pakistan is and what do you think
the United States is doing to keep an
eye on its nuclear arsenal well I think
we do a pretty good job keeping an eye
on the Arsenal I think we keep an eye on
their arsenal since late 2001 when US
forces showed up in civilian clothing to
provide assistance and oversight we were
terribly concerned about Pakistan's
Arsenal I don't see Pakistan is very
stable at all
I think it has improved its stability
over the past few months I think
Musharraf the President of Pakistan has
fired enough people that he may have
some control over the situation in
Pakistan but I think it's highly
explosive US troops in the Middle East
has helped his stability no I don't
think it's helped his stability but we
have to remember that the stability of
the Pakistani government did not extend
to blocking the ISI from supporting the
Taliban so it was not in the United
States interest to stabilize Pakistan
after 9/11 along the lines that were in
place there it was an interest of the
United States to create sufficient
instability in Pakistan to force
Musharraf to turn on his lies in the ISI
and that necessarily created a more
unstable situation there are
circumstances which instability is not
in the American interest and that was
one um Johnson ability I should say
jumping ahead a little bit because we're
actually running out of time I just
realized let's let's jump to to Iraq and
the
invasion and the reasons for the
invasion of Iraq how wide of a gulf do
you think there is between the reasons
that the administration put forth for
invading Iraq and their actual reasons
for invading around here it's an
enormous gulf well I can prove to you
categorically they did not invade Iraq
because of weapons of mass destruction
because if you think the country has
weapons of mass destruction they're
about to use you don't announce it a
year before and give them a chance to
build it up one of the myths is the rush
to war in fact there was such a long gap
between the announcement that we were
interested in dating the actual invasion
that if we actually thought there were
nuclear weapons there for example it
would have been totally responsible the
reason for the invasion has to be
understood by going back to March of
2002 when the first decisions have made
the Afghan war is over it's kind of a
success
the planned we're going to go all over
the world hunt down al Qaeda wherever
they are kill them it's a wonderful plan
nobody knows how to do it I can't find
them what happens next and the
administration is confronted with this
problem it can either move into homeland
defense ie
wait for the next attack or do something
and there are no good choices the heart
of the matter they begin to realize is
the money that's flowing to al Qaeda and
the money that's flowing to al Qaeda is
flowing from Saudi Arabia not from the
Saudi government per se but from figures
in Saudi Arabia and the Saudi government
is not prepared to crackdown them the
u.s. goes to the Saudis Colin Powell
goes to the Saudis and says we need your
help they not only refuse but they order
US forces out of Saudi Arabia suddenly
we have a Saudi crisis what do we do
about Saudi Arabia we don't have a good
answer for that
the Saudis simply aren't going to
cooperate because I said before they're
more afraid of al-qaeda they don't think
the United States is going to launch a
war without Saudi support because for 50
years Saudi Arabia has been the
foundation of US strategic policy in the
region it's not going to happen the
administration realizes two things one
it has to get a heavy lever on Saudi
Arabia and two it has got to demonstrate
its willingness to go to war that this
is getting out of hand nobody thinks
we're going to do anything decisive
there's a psychological component to
this we could invade Saudi Arabia if you
look at a map that's hard moreover and
here's welcomes in not because we want
to control the oil fields of the Middle
East that's kind of not what's going on
but we certainly don't want to disrupt
the flow of Saudi oil because that will
disrupt the world economy something
fierce the question that comes up how do
we get the Saudis to realize one that
we're serious and to begin operating on
our behalf
Iraq happens to be the most strategic
country in the Middle East it's the key
to the Middle East at borders Kuwait
Saudi Arabia Jordan Syria Turkey Iran if
there was no Saddam Hussein and you were
as a military planner to say where do
you want your basis it's Iraq it's the
key because from Iraq you can reach out
and touch anyone okay plus there's
Saddam there plus the administration
also believes that there's weapons of
mass destruction if you include chemical
weapons you've got chemical weapons of
mass destruction they believe it the
Russians believe that the French believe
it I believe it there's no one in the
game who doesn't believe they have it
that's not why they invade because this
point they get cute they have a very
complicated strategic plan which is hard
to explain plus you don't want to expand
to the world and we're going in there to
scare the living daylights other the
Saudis it's hard for the Saudis the back
of their position so instead they come
up with what they think is a great read
we're going in because as weapons of
mass destruction why because Bill
Clinton had executed Operation Desert
Fox in December 1998 over the same issue
who is going to object it is an idea fix
and US intelligence that there is there
are weapons of mass destruction well
there are lots of people who wound up
objecting but the point was that the
Saudis did they changed their behavior
about a week before the invasion
when they finally became convinced that
this really was going to happen and I
spoke with many of these about three
weeks before they said no no no we know
it won't they allowed us a wax into
Saudi airspace and after the invasion
they started cracking down on al Qaeda
proof al Qaeda started attacking the
royal family so the policy changed the
invasion which had massive mistakes and
failures built into it than in the way
it was executed the invasion achieved
its primary strategic goal and al Qaeda
was deeply weakened by the cutoff of the
flow of money but the administration got
trapped not in a lie because it believed
it to be true but it get trapped in the
truth too turned out to be false and
could now be accused of fabricating a
justification for go to war it's a
complicated story but the goal was that
the two divisions to the north of Saudi
Arabia should be American not Iraqi and
that would change the entire Saudi
worldview it did so we then however
wound up because of huge intelligence
failures having nothing to do with WMD
that was not the biggest the failure to
understand it Saddam Hussein had a
follow-on war plan designed to bog the
United States down to guerilla war and
that Iranian intelligence had organized
the Shiites in the south so they were
going to welcome us as liberators they
already organized by moiez which is the
intelligence service
those are the massive failures those are
the ones were paying for now and that
goes back to what I think is George
Bush's biggest single failure in the war
his failure to fire senior commanders of
the intelligence community and hold him
responsible after December 7th
Eisenhower fired sink package commander
in chief Pacific Michael Kimmel not
because he did anything wrong
probably didn't but because he had to
signal that the whole world had changed
and he found people Colonels like
Eisenhower Patton Bradley Nimitz and no
one had ever heard of and he rotated
them to the top and these are the men
who led the battles that won the war
Bush stayed with a team that had made
mistake after mistake after mistake and
that is the inexplicable part he finally
fired tended to resigned whatever story
you want to believe way too late because
that CIA under him failed to provide the
intelligence that leaves us to the
Battle of Fallujah tonight and no one
was held accountable for that so this is
a classic case where the strategy in my
opinion was sound and understandable the
execution from the military standpoint
was excellent and the intelligence
failures were catastrophic have time for
just one more question and I reserve the
right look into your crystal ball always
dangerous in Iraq the situation right
now maybe not going so good what do you
see in the next year and do you see it
becoming the quagmire that that has been
predicted so many times it depends on
your definition of quagmire do I see
violence going away no but I actually
see the situation is better than most
people do
let's first begin by the fact that
Shiite areas and the Kurdish areas are
pretty stable the fight is in the Sunni
triangle and the fight is with the
sheiks who lead the Sunni community the
elders if you will those elders have
provided support through their
population to the guerrillas from the
beginning is a very small group of
guerrillas people compare this to
Vietnam that's insane
there were over a million troops
available to North Vietnamese five to
ten thousand most are operating Iraq
without sanctuary if the Sunni
leadership pulls their support for the
guerrillas the guerrillas will degrade
not disappear but they will degrade as
we fight the Battle of Fallujah the real
audience of that or the Sunni leadership
and we're sending two messages one we
are crazy enough to do this very
important war to demonstrate an element
of rationality and - there's still seat
at the table for you guys and we use
everything from bribes to positions in
the future government to get them in or
you can stay where you are and Fallujah
will be followed by city after City
after City now right now the Sunni
leadership is thinking very long and
hard about the fact that George Bush
will be President that he is undoubtedly
vicious brutal and crazy and therefore
do you want to deal with a man like this
when you've only got five to ten
thousand troops out there
I think the Fallujah attack did not
accidentally begin exactly after the war
after the election it was the signal to
the Sunni leadership that you have a
fundamental strategic decision to make
and my suspicion is that sufficient
numbers of the Sunni leadership are
going to shift their position they don't
have that much loyalty to our Cowie that
we will see over the coming months a
degradation
in the level of violence not eliminating
it but certainly on the order of
something that is far more tolerable and
remember you could tolerate the Irish
Republican Army in Northern Ireland for
years I don't see the situation as that
bad I think the US has more support in
the Shiite areas and the Kurdish areas
that people realize and I think right
now
this shifting inside the Sunni areas I
think that Iraq itself right now is
actually stabilizing and a year from now
we'll come back and apologize for that
if everyone very good thank you very
much ladies and gentlemen dr. George
Friedman good job dr. Friedman will be
signing books right over here if you
have a book with you that you've
purchased at book people you can get in
line if you don't have one yet I believe
they're available down on the first
floor you can pay for them and bring
them up here thank you very much for
coming out tonight
George Friedman is author of the
intelligence edge and the future of war
his